hagamos un par de ejemplos graficando
ecuaciones lineales hay un buen de
formas de graficar esto lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo es la más básica
vamos a agarrar un buen de valores vamos
a ver qué valores toma la ecuación y
conectarlos los puntos voy a reescribir
esto en caso de que no lo vean y es
igual a 12 x + 7 y lo que quiere es
graficar esta ecuación lineal antes de
tomar la gráfica vamos a poner una tabla
voy a tomar un buen de valores de x y
ver qué valor de ye le corresponde a
cada uno de esos valores así que por
ejemplo si x es igual a empezar con algo
muy pequeño digamos si x es igual a
menos 2
quien es y entonces sustituimos menos 2
en la ecuación y esto sería 2 x menos 2
+ 7 y esto es menos 47 que es igual a 3
si x es igual a estoy agarrando valores
al azar oa lo mejor puedo irme saltando
en dos o tres unidades bueno no no sé
pero bueno qué tal si x es cero entonces
y es igual a 2 x 0 + 7 y esto es igual a
muy bien ahora qué tal si bueno ya que
estoy subiendo de dos en dos podría
subir de uno en uno tomando números al
azar pero bueno qué tal si x es 2
entonces ponemos 2 por 2 más 7 y esto es
4 + 7 que es igual a 11 y puedo seguir
graficando este puntos como yo quiera de
hecho yo para graficar una línea sólo
necesito dos puntos verdad así que
realmente ya tenemos uno demás déjenme
déjenme poner otro punto más para que
vean que en efecto es una línea cuando x
es igual a es más vamos a ponerle que
sea 8 sólo para agarrar un número un
número al azar entonces esto será 2 x 8
+ 7 y 2 por 8 son 16 y si le sumamos
luego 7 nos da 23 muy bien ahora vamos a
graficar lo déjenme hacer mi eje y
aquí justamente ok aquí está mi eje x y
tenemos un buen de valores positivos así
que vamos a dejar más más espacio del
lado positivo ahí es también hey cuando
uso cuando cuando x vale menos 2 es el
mínimo déjenme sigo poniendo puntos aquí
está el 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
ok estos son nuestros valores de x y
luego nos subimos en los valores de y
déjenme hacerlo en otra escala porque
estos crecen de forma muy rápida así que
voy a hacerlo en incrementos de 2
muy bien hasta aquí estaría el 2 el 4 el
6 el 8 el 10 12 14 y 16 y bueno podría
seguir hacia arriba pero bueno vamos a
graficar estos puntos así que la primera
coordina coordenada que tengo es x igual
a menos dos igual a tres así que escribo
mi coordenada vamos a poner el punto
menos 2,3 ok
3 más o menos cae por este lado y este
es nuestro primer punto el menos 23
ahora nuestro siguiente punto el 07
vamos a hacerlo en otro color 0 x 0 y es
igual a 7 y está justo aquí 0,7 y
tenemos este otro en verde el 2,11 211
más o menos anda por acá
2,11 y el último punto bueno este se
sale de mi gráfica verdad del 8,23 no se
estaría muy arriba digamos por acá e
incluso pueden ver más o menos cómo se
sigue comportando no si conectamos los
puntos vamos a formar una línea que
conectan todos estos puntos y obviamente
este dibujo no va a salir perfecto no es
una línea derechita pero si tuviéramos
una computadora si saldría bien no si
tomamos más valores de xy gráfica mos
sus valores correspondientes de ye
porque en esta en este caso es una
función que depende de x
si seguimos graficando todos estos
posibles valores de x tendremos una
línea recta vamos a hacer otro problema
en el aeropuerto tú puedes cambiar tu
dinero por de dólares a euros ok
entonces el servicio te cuesta cinco
dólares y por cada dólar adicional tú
tienes punto siete euros
ok tienes siete euros y hace una tabla
para esto y gráfica la función en una
gráfica usa tu gráfica para determinar
cuántos euros puedes obtener de la
oficina con 50 dólares y entonces voy a
escribir euros es igual vamos a ver va a
ser dólares los dólares
y de ahí vamos a quitarle 55 dólares
verdad así que inmediatamente este
servicio cuesta 5 y luego todo esto
vamos a multiplicarlo por punto 7
ok punto 7 lo que sea que eso nos dé
esta relación es la ecuación que nos
determina los euros en términos de los
dólares y si les damos 50 dólares pues
simplemente hay que sustituir entonces
tenemos euros va a ser 0.7 y en vez de
dólares pongo 50 menos 5
así que por qué tomaron 5 como la tarifa
verdad del servicio así que esto es 45 y
por punto 7 bueno eso lo puede hacer
justamente aquí verdad 45 por 0.7 es
igual a 7 por 5 35 y llevo 37 por 4 28 y
estos tres son 31 y como solo tengo un
número a la derecha del punto decimal
solo recorre el punto decimal una unidad
a la izquierda así que si les damos 50
dólares tendremos 31.5 euros no dólares
son euros así que ya respondimos la la
pregunta vamos a hacer una tabla
a lo mejor valdría la pena tener a la
mano la calculadora así que digamos
tengo dólares
y cuántos euros tengo en cada caso
sólo voy a poner un buen de números al
azar digamos y les damos 5 dólares vamos
y bueno toman 5 dólares de tarifa
entonces voy a tener 5 menos 50 por
punto 70 así que no hay razón para hacer
eso verdad ahora si les damos 10 dólares
qué va a pasar si les damos 10 dólares
10 menos 55 por punto 7 es 3.5 verdad
tendríamos 3.5 euros muy bien ahora qué
pasa si yo les doy 30 dólares
qué pasa si les damos 30 dólares saber
entonces bueno déjenme ponerle mejor 25
si les damos 25 25
5 son 20 y 20 por punto 7 son 14 euros
muy bien ahora vamos a hacer un último
digamos que le damos 55 esto esto hace
fácil las matemáticas verdad porque le
restamos el 5 de las unidades entonces
para 55 nos quedan 35 euros- verdad es
correcto si justo
entonces tendremos treinta y cinco euros
y lo que quiero es graficar ahora esto
todos estos valores son positivos así
que lo voy a dibujar en el primer
cuadrante todo esto en el primer
cuadrante
muy bien entonces los dólares van
incrementándose digamos de 5 en 5 5 10
15 20 25 30 35 40 45 50 55 sale
este es mi eje x voy a tener que
ampliarlo hasta 55 y luego en el eje voy
a incrementar de 55 vamos a poner 5 10
15 20 25
y 35
y ahora sí ya quedó bien ahora vamos a
graficar estos puntos digamos si tenemos
5 tenemos cero euros aquí este es el eje
de los euros verdad y estos son de los
dólares los dólares es la variable
independiente y euros dependen del
número de dólares que yo tengo verdad si
le doy 10 dólares obtengo 3.5 euros más
o menos como por aquí si le doy 25
dólares voy a tener 14 euros más o menos
por aquí obviamente pues mi dibujo no va
a ser totalmente exacto pero bueno si
tengo 55 dólares voy a tener 35 euros
que es más o menos por aquí y si quiero
conectar estos puntos de verde debería
tener algo que se parece pues mucho a
una línea si lo hiciera en la
computadora sería una línea exacta pero
bueno estoy en este salió más o menos
bien así que qué es lo que nos piden
hacer usar la gráfica para determinar
cuántos euros tendríamos si le damos a
la oficina 50 dólares así que vamos
muy bien y aquí en la gráfica
ok aquí dibujé hasta
este punto en la gráfica quizás está un
poquito incorrecto déjenme
ok entonces 35 está aquí déjenme
redibujar este punto
este debería estar justo aquí ok este
así que ahora déjenme redibujar mi línea
aquí en 25 vale 14 muy bien así que mi
gráfica realmente debería lucir más o
menos así este es mi mejor esfuerzo
ahora déjenme responderla la pregunta
teníamos 50 subimos subimos subimos aquí
y la persona va a obtener digamos nos
vamos hasta la izquierda y más o menos
vemos que tiene 31.5 y esto lo podemos
obtener de nuestra fórmula pero si
tenemos un buen ojo podemos más o menos
saber desde la gráfica cuánto tendremos
por ejemplo en 20 tendremos
para 20 tendremos como 750 2 perdón
euros y la imprecisión de mi gráfica
hace que esto sea mucho menos exacto
pero digamos que 20 menos 5 son 15 y 15
por punto 7
sí y anda por aquí más o menos si
ponemos 20 aquí en la ecuación tendremos
20 menos 5 que es 15 y 15 por punto 7 es
10.5 euros que está justo aquí así que
si miras en la gráfica podremos también
ver cuántos euros obtenemos vamos a
hacer este otro
la gráfica perdón la gráfica de abajo
nos muestra una gráfica de conversión
para cambiar el peso en kilogramos en
peso en libras usarla para convertir las
siguientes medidas y tenemos aquí
kilogramos y acá libras quieren que
convirtamos cuatro kilogramos en libras
así que nos situamos en el 44 kilogramos
aquí justamente seguimos hasta arriba
hasta donde está la gráfica y 4
kilogramos en libras parece no lo sé es
un poquito debajo de 9 libras así que un
poquito menos que bueno digamos casi 9
libras
ok no podemos verlo exactamente es un
poquito menos pero bueno esos son 4
kilogramos ahora 9 kilogramos nos vamos
directamente aquí subimos todo este
camino hasta la gráfica y son 20 libras
si son 20 libras ahora nos dicen 20
libras en peso de kilogramos pero bueno
ahora nos situamos en 12 libras
12 libras
y esto lo bajamos a los kilogramos que
esto es más o menos como 55 y medio 5.5
ahora 17 libras digamos estamos por aquí
esto parece más o menos como 7.5
kilogramos siete y medio ok
de cualquier forma espero que estos
ejemplos te hayan servido un poco para
que te hayan hecho sentir cómodo con la
gráfica de las ecuaciones nos vemos en
el próximo vídeo